right now more reaction to all tonight's
big breaking news in the comments by
Merrick Garland the AG and also the
growing effort inside the Biden FBI and
doj to politicize Justice constitutional
law professor Fox News contributor
Jonathan Turley Jonathan you know what
you're a pretty fair Arbiter you really
are you're a Democrat we don't agree on
everything politically but you you kind
of call them as you see him you call
balls and Strikes I'll give you a lot of
credit for that there's not many in the
media that do you tell me if I'm wrong
in my thinking after all that we went
through with first attempt to tie Donald
Trump to Russia through the alpha bank
and and the Trump Tower servers
connected to the Russian bank that was
all a lie they tried to push that on the
American people then Hillary pays for a
dossier with money that she funneled
through a law firm that hired Fusion GPS
that hired Christopher Steele then it's
all unverifiable now debunked
information in that dossier but yet they
were warned before they ever applied for
the first fisa application but they used
it anyway they used it four times it
says at the top of a fisa application
verified that was signed three of them
was signed by James Comey himself then
you think of people like Peter strzok
and his words they had an insurance
policy so Donald Trump wouldn't get
elected Am I Wrong are others wrong and
are are genuine distrust of the FBI and
the doj you know look at the treatment
of Peter Navarro recently or the
treatment of Paul manafort or Roger
Stone who we're going to talk to am I
wrong in thinking that if you're a
conservative you're treated one way and
if you're Hillary Clinton if you're a
Biden you get treated another way
no that's precisely why this raid seems
to me rather Reckless and that is the
attorney general has to weigh that
context this country is a Tinderbox and
he has an agency in the FBI that has a
documented history of false statements a
documented history of misleading courts
and you have to consider that before you
approve a raid of this kind and one of
the things that struck me with your
initial comment Sean with these sources
is how they describe this warrant they
they told you that there were two things
described in the warrant one a general
category of material that should have
been turned over to the archives under
the presidential records Act and the
second one was a general reference to
possibly classified information if that
description is accurate it is very
concerning first of all the first
category I think you have to just set
aside the pra is not a criminal statute
it's not ordinarily enforced using these
types of heavy-handed tactics what all
of us were looking for in this warrant
and maybe we'll see it is a specificity
that they had specific documents in mind
with a very high level of classification
documents that the Trump people had
refused to turn over that's the
specificity we're looking for that's the
type of thing that would legitimate
bringing this to or escalating this to a
higher level what your sources describe
is not that and so we'll see what
happens with this warrant but when when
the Attorney General was speaking all of
us had the same reaction in the field
which is we're not that interested in
the warrant as opposed to the affidavit
that's where we would find out what the
court was told the award itself is sort
of the conclusions it describes the
parameters of the search well we want to
know is why this search was ordered what
was told to the court and did they
reveal that there had been cooperation
with the first subpoena
well the the we have the letter from
February from the National Archives and
the doj FBI Representatives they went to
Mar-A-Lago as late as June and the
president met with them personally and
said they welcome back any time and they
requested a padlock be put on the room
with where some of these boxes were and
the the Trump people complied and were
as helpful as can be so I would like to
see that affidavit as well uh but what
about going to a magistrate that on
social media is trashed the morality of
Donald Trump uh given money to Barack
Obama uh and and also defended sorry I
know everyone deserves a defense uh
defended people associated with of all
people Jeffrey Epstein doesn't sound
like the guy that I would want to go to
for for such a warrant like this
well I think what is surprising is that
this was handled by a magistrate a
matter of this importance you would
think would go to an article 3 judge or
that the magistrate would bring in the
article 3 judge uh to basically confirm
that this should this is the correct
course of action but we're going to have
to see that affidavit now we don't know
they may have found classified
information the government has a right
to retrieve that information but it's
also important to note that this is a
fairly common
conflict between former presidents and
the archives material is taken all the
time that the archive says that's that
needs to be brought back even Furniture
has been taken out of the White House
that didn't belong to former presidents
and so this is not that uncommon and if
they found those types of documents the
question Still Remains why couldn't you
have done that with a less intrusive
means the Attorney General today said
there was no other possible or less
intrusive means that's what left a lot
of us scratching our heads I I can think
of a lot of Alternatives and this
warrant hopefully will explain why you
didn't think that there was any other
possibility but it's really the
affidavit that will tell us whether they
had a good faith basis well a good faith
basis or whether they trumped up charges
no pun intended anyway Jonathan Turley
thank you we appreciate your time hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else